[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, by 2 p.m., Paul Ribeiro has returned to the Palace of Jeon, going through the different fortifications and into the royal chambers.
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_01]: You gotta look for Jeon.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you want to go up to his private offices?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: You get there, it's around 2 p.m., and his guards are outside in front as normal.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you go up to them and what do you say?
[SPEAKER_01]: I need to speak to Prince Jeon, please.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I ask?
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I tell him what this is about?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm Paul.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, Paul.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's very busy.
[SPEAKER_01]: What is it?
[SPEAKER_00]: It's important matters.
[SPEAKER_00]: Regarding?
[SPEAKER_00]: Not your concern.
[SPEAKER_01]: I see.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll see if he will see you.
[SPEAKER_01]: He walks into the chamber.
[SPEAKER_01]: Normally, John would have scheduled a time with you.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, he was attentive, but obviously very, very
[SPEAKER_01]: He was concerned about making sure things were done in a way.
[SPEAKER_01]: He didn't want to give you access to them all the time, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: But the guard does come back out and he says, he'll see you, opens the door, and Jeon is behind the desk.
[SPEAKER_01]: You walk in, and the guard closes the door behind you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Jeon says to you,
[SPEAKER_01]: Paul, this better be important.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm very busy.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're dealing with a blockade now.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I've heard.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have learned a very great important news regarding me and my mother and my father.
[SPEAKER_01]: That was quick.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: I found these letters that were written to my mother by a man of name Grayson, which I believe is my father, and is the son of Miss Jamis.
[SPEAKER_00]: Lady Jamis?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have spoken with her already.
[SPEAKER_01]: The son of Lady Jamis, but not Lord Jamis?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, Lord Jamis.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ah, Lord Jamis isn't Lady Jamis' son.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, I knew Grace and his boy.
[SPEAKER_00]: These letters confirm that he is my father.
[SPEAKER_00]: Where did you find these?
[SPEAKER_00]: I found them in my mother's room in a chest, hidden away.
[SPEAKER_01]: I had searched her room many times.
[SPEAKER_01]: Where was it hidden?
[SPEAKER_00]: There was a closet.
[SPEAKER_01]: The old chambers?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: The old secrets?
[SPEAKER_01]: Who's they?
[SPEAKER_01]: Your mother.
[SPEAKER_01]: Grayson.
[SPEAKER_01]: Someone else.
[SPEAKER_01]: Obviously they had found it.
[SPEAKER_01]: I knew she wanted that room for a reason.
[SPEAKER_01]: She was very tricky in her ways.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're sure it's Grayson here?
[SPEAKER_01]: These letters prove it?
[SPEAKER_01]: Read them.
[SPEAKER_01]: He starts going through it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically,
[SPEAKER_01]: He has a scowl on his face at the beginning, but as he reads through the letters, you can tell that he is relieved.
[SPEAKER_01]: Actually, he starts nodding and looking at these things.
[SPEAKER_01]: And says to you, Well, Paul, I must say, you brought great peace to my mind.
[SPEAKER_01]: I thought I would.
[SPEAKER_01]: The scandal back 23 years ago was hard enough.
[SPEAKER_01]: But honestly, Grayson Jamis is
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, I can accept him as your father much more than I can others.
[SPEAKER_01]: Jason was a good man.
[SPEAKER_01]: He was honorable and intelligent and I'm glad to know that he loved your mother.
[SPEAKER_01]: They were inseparable as children and I think your mother had a great fondness for him and I'm glad to know that
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm glad to know that he is your father.
[SPEAKER_01]: Below your station, or my station as it were, your mother's station.
[SPEAKER_01]: But things could have been much worse.
[SPEAKER_00]: What do you mean?
[SPEAKER_01]: The letters mention this man, Archibald.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, I know of him.
[SPEAKER_01]: He was a demon, Paul.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the thought of you coming from him was unbearable to me.
[SPEAKER_01]: He was cruel.
[SPEAKER_01]: He was arrogant.
[SPEAKER_01]: He thought himself above all stations, even though he had no name.
[SPEAKER_00]: The worst part about him, however,
[SPEAKER_01]: Was that he was brilliant.
[SPEAKER_01]: His mind was like no others.
[SPEAKER_01]: And his charm, although it was false, was incredible.
[SPEAKER_01]: I learned at a very young age what Archibald truly was.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because as he would charm those that were above him and manipulate them to his will,
[SPEAKER_01]: Those that were weaker than him, he would torture.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he knew how to do it in such a way that it would never come back to him.
[SPEAKER_01]: His torture, you see, was not physical.
[SPEAKER_01]: Not always.
[SPEAKER_01]: Even though if he thought he could get away with that, he would.
[SPEAKER_01]: It was mental.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the mental anguish that he caused me, even though I was older than him,
[SPEAKER_01]: Was not insignificant.
[SPEAKER_01]: I always told my father that he was not a good influence on your mother and still he brought
[SPEAKER_01]: Your mother, Grayson, and other couriers in our land into his orbit to do what he did.
[SPEAKER_01]: I could see through him though, and I knew what he really was.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not a man of value, but a man of vanity.
[SPEAKER_01]: To be honest with you, my keeping in you at arm's length all these years had nothing to do with your deformity.
[SPEAKER_01]: It had to do with knowing this secret.
[SPEAKER_01]: Whether or not Grayson was your father or forbid it, Archibald Fryholm was your father.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have watched you over the years and I think you as aloof, I think you as
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, socially inept in some cases.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, I don't see you as a cruel man.
[SPEAKER_01]: Archibald was that cruel.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I don't know if it was your deformities that saved you from being able to develop his character, manipulate people,
[SPEAKER_01]: It is good though that I know now that it is Grayson.
[SPEAKER_01]: This takes away many concerns from me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Good to know?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's also good to know that your mother favored Grayson over Archibald.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the fact that she would never tell me was torture beyond belief.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: As you read the letters, you'll know that there's a man named Zafar.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, I know Zafar Azane very well.
[SPEAKER_00]: I was speaking with Lady Jamis.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have asked her if I could meet him.
[SPEAKER_00]: She said that she would ask, but it's not guaranteed.
[SPEAKER_00]: Why would you wish to meet Zafar Azane?
[SPEAKER_00]: Because I have questions to ask him about what happened to my father.
[SPEAKER_01]: He plays with the letters a little.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can tell that he's conflicted.
[SPEAKER_00]: I might need to travel to see him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Travel where?
[SPEAKER_00]: Where do I need to go again?
[SPEAKER_00]: The key?
[SPEAKER_00]: Gradsul is where he is, supposedly.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know we are in conflict with the Duke of Rolla right now.
[SPEAKER_01]: The Duke of Gradsul and the Rolla family are currently blockading our fleet and the trade routes that come to Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: I do know that.
[SPEAKER_01]: I know very well.
[SPEAKER_00]: This would be very dangerous for you to go there as a member of the royal house.
[SPEAKER_00]: I know what I'm getting into.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I don't think you do know what you're getting into.
[SPEAKER_01]: I know what I'm asking for.
[SPEAKER_01]: You may know what you're asking for, but truthfully, you do not know what you're getting into.
[SPEAKER_01]: Zvar Huzain is probably one of the most powerful wizards in the Flaness at this time.
[SPEAKER_01]: And it's not clear to me just whose side he is on.
[SPEAKER_01]: He has come to us for diplomatic
[SPEAKER_01]: Negotiations between me and the Duke of Gradsul.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, not much has been brought.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm not afraid that Zafar necessarily would betray us.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, I see the Duke of Rola using you as a pawn in this game that we're playing.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have no doubt that he would capture you and hold you to gain some leverage on me.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think it is impossible for you to go to Gradsul.
[SPEAKER_01]: I doubt that he'd catch me.
[SPEAKER_01]: You doubt that the Duke of Gradsul would catch you?
[SPEAKER_00]: You guys barely know where I am half the time.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ah, well, we don't look that often.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's the truth.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, the principalities, we have a good spy network, and Jamis has done a good job.
[SPEAKER_01]: Casting his net.
[SPEAKER_01]: They all know you, though, Paul, and they know to leave you alone.
[SPEAKER_01]: Don't think the Duke of Gradsul doesn't have anything as professional as what we have, especially in Gradsul itself.
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, Paul, it is too dangerous.
[SPEAKER_01]: What else did Lady Azane tell you, though?
[SPEAKER_01]: Did she say she would go and send messages?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, wait a second.
[SPEAKER_01]: Did we talk about it?
[SPEAKER_01]: Did you even mention Lady Azane?
[SPEAKER_01]: Lady Jamis?
[SPEAKER_01]: You didn't, did you?
[SPEAKER_01]: I didn't mention Lady Jamis.
[SPEAKER_00]: You did?
[SPEAKER_01]: I didn't mention it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: What else has Lady Jamis told you?
[SPEAKER_01]: Did she say she would contact her brother?
[SPEAKER_01]: She would try.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can you be patient?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: For me?
[SPEAKER_01]: I think you will have that conversation with Zafar Zayn.
[SPEAKER_01]: He is the ambassador to the Sea Principalities.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I'll take it upon myself to send a message, a letter,
[SPEAKER_01]: To the Duke of Rola asking for diplomatic relations at this time.
[SPEAKER_01]: It is no doubt to me that a Zayn, Zafar Zayn, will come himself.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll leave it to Lady Jamis.
[SPEAKER_01]: To get you an audience with her.
[SPEAKER_01]: Would that suffice?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Good.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, to other matters.
[SPEAKER_01]: May I keep these?
[SPEAKER_01]: Why?
[SPEAKER_01]: Just that of affection for your sister.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you wish to keep them, I'll give them back to you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do I believe he's telling me the truth?
[SPEAKER_00]: Do an insight roll.
[SPEAKER_00]: No way.
[SPEAKER_01]: Which roll?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a 17.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's not telling you the truth.
[SPEAKER_01]: And in fact, what you think is, he means to use these to go confront Jamis.
[SPEAKER_01]: Something you don't really know if you want or not.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, you may not keep this, Jeon.
[SPEAKER_00]: I would please like to look at them more.
[SPEAKER_01]: Of course.
Thank you.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you have talked to, you have showed these to others.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Who?
[SPEAKER_00]: Miss Janus.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have a job for you.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you would take it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's hear it.
[SPEAKER_01]: I know that you have not been in the foreign district very often.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a wild place.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, I have rumors that there are agents of the Prince of Toli
[SPEAKER_01]: Unofficially residing in that province.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to let you, I'm going to tell you something that must be kept sacred.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm all yours.
[SPEAKER_01]: I believe that Prince of Toli is working against us with the Duke of Rola.
[SPEAKER_01]: With the Duke of Kratzel.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I want you to find out.
[SPEAKER_01]: I want you to find out if there are any agents from Toli in the foreign district.
[SPEAKER_00]: And do what with them?
[SPEAKER_01]: Nothing.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't want you to kill or try to be in conflict with anyone.
[SPEAKER_01]: These men are dangerous.
[SPEAKER_01]: If they are who I think they are, they are Toli assassins that work for Prince Saknod themselves.
[SPEAKER_01]: These men are magical assassins.
[SPEAKER_01]: They know magic as only the Toli do and the Seul do.
[SPEAKER_01]: Keep your distance.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can recognize them as Suel.
[SPEAKER_01]: Track them down.
[SPEAKER_01]: Observe them.
[SPEAKER_01]: See who they meet.
[SPEAKER_01]: See who they talk to.
[SPEAKER_00]: It will be done.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have reason to believe
[SPEAKER_01]: That there is somebody in our employ that has been working closely with them.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do not kill anyone or only do so if absolutely necessary.
[SPEAKER_00]: I understand.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can you start on this tonight?
[SPEAKER_00]: There's something I want to do, but I'll get on it first thing tomorrow morning.
[SPEAKER_01]: When you go to the foreign district, be sure that no one knows who you are.
[SPEAKER_01]: Select a cloak.
[SPEAKER_01]: I understand.
[SPEAKER_01]: Here.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll have something brought to your room.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right, Paul.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tomorrow.
[SPEAKER_01]: You said you want the rest of the day, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: So anyway, where do you want to go now?
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to go back to my room and grab the book and I want to make the homunculus thingy.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you go back to your room, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you grab the homunculus toad.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're reading through it and
[SPEAKER_01]: Someone knocks on your door and what do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_00]: Let him in.
[SPEAKER_00]: Open the door and see who it is.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you open the door and it's one of the servants and he's got this large chest basically in his arms, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: And there are a couple of other servants behind him that have these large
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, armloads full of clothing, cloaks and other such stuff.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the servant bows to you and says, Lord Jeon, Prince Jeon, bade that we bring these to you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so they bring the chest in and put it on your table, and then they take the clothing, and it's like a whole bunch of clothing, and they're like, where should we put this?
[SPEAKER_01]: Just put it on the bed.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so they go over and dump robes, different clothing, all these like, they're like tattered stuff, beggar's clothing, shit like that on your bed.
[SPEAKER_01]: Beggar's clothing?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I mean, just like weird crap, you know, onto your bed and give it to you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: They bow, and then they walk out.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I guess I start looking for what to wear.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you start looking, picking through the stuff?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to look in the chest?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, what's in the chest?
[SPEAKER_01]: Makeup.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wax.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hair.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do an 8 check.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's an 8.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eh, eight plus three.
[SPEAKER_01]: You realize that this basically is a bunch of materials to disguise yourself and to change what you look like, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: There are masks among the clothing that
[SPEAKER_01]: You know, paths for different looking people.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, this wouldn't be something that would confuse somebody if they looked really closely at you.
[SPEAKER_01]: But maybe if you had a cloak on and that, they wouldn't be able to see your burns underneath your face.
[SPEAKER_01]: Much more, I would say, concealing than your leather mask that literally makes you look like a whore or a hangman.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's cool.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll leave that there for now.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: What's with the clothes?
[SPEAKER_00]: Just basically, you can select any kind of outfit that you want to look like.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to look like a beggar?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to look like a guard?
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want to look like a merchant?
[SPEAKER_00]: Basically, what he's giving you is a set of costumes that you can use to dress yourself up as whatever you'd like.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just give me a big black cloak with a hood over it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Regular casual wear underneath it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, what you're going to do is you're going to put this away.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to costume up right now or would you rather go through the Book of the Humball?
[SPEAKER_00]: Keep doing this.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now.